good evening everybody and welcome to
this overview and scrutiny committee on
wednesday the 23rd of march
my name is councillor vanessa bell and
i'm the chairman of this committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
rules to run through
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and be by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak and i will then invite
you at the proper time
when invited to speak please turn on
your microphone and speak clearly
the recording does depend on correct use
of the microphone so even though we can
all hear ourselves in here we do need to
use the mics so thank you
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers
and keep your contributions please as
clear and concise as possible and then
when you're not speaking please turn
your microphones off
finally can i draw your attention to the
fire exits which is the door behind this
table and the door over there and the
fact that there are no longer uneven
surfaces in the chamber
okay apologies for absence tara if i can
have the apologies for absence please
yes thank you very much apologies have
been received from councillor miss beale
councillor hoovner councillor helm
councillor mays and council schemes
thank you chairman thank you thank you
very much um we're in a position with
item three because uh i'm recommending
that the minutes of the meeting held on
20th january 20th of january found on
pages five to eight are approved as a
true and accurate record but i think i
was the only person here so
where does that leave me procedurally
sarah
and i think it's fine for you to agree
then if you're not happy we can always
defer to the next meeting
as far as far as i remember they're
they're too inaccurate so i'm happy to
agree them and uh i'll catch the
messenger i just think uh thank you
chairman i just i i think i was present
so uh
i can i can't remember you'll be on the
minute i should be there my name
be on the minutes let's just if i am
then i can i can help you to uh approve
those minutes i get confused because we
have of course we have the crime and
disorder in between so
[Music]
where are we
oh yes hello you were
you were i take it back council
messenger are you happy to agree the
minutes
thank you madam chairman yes i am thank
you
those minutes are agreed
marvelous they need to do something
about my memory
okay item four declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
members any
nope
that's the stamp i mean i'm not a member
of this committee but i am actually
going to speak so i don't know if you
just wish me to declare that i'm a
member of essex county council and i
think there's none pecuniary interest on
any items on the agenda at the moment
thank you better to be safe than sorry
counselor stan thanks very much
item five public participation and i can
advise that we have not received any
submissions from members of the public
for this meeting
so that brings us on to item six the
annual report of the overview and
scrutiny committee which you'll find on
pages 11 to 14.
so i will now hand over to ms hughes
please to present the report if you
would thank you
good evening members
uh it's within the committee terms of
reference to prepare and present an
annual report for council
officers in the working group of the
committee have prepared a suggested
report as set out page 9 to 13 of your
agenda pack
this highlights the activity that's
taken place this year
section 3.2 details the scrutiny items
that closed this year but were agreed in
2021
and provides a summary of what came out
of them
section 3.5 details the proposals we've
received from members within the year
including information on what the
committee decided and any actions that
have come out of investigation work
members are invited to review the report
and feedback on the draft annual report
and the recommendation is that the
committee endorses the proposed annual
report
thank you thank you very much miss
hughes i just wanted to uh raise one
issue which is
the
how the young self-build register
which was councillor white's item
councilwhite had actually followed that
up and did request that more work was
done however somehow the email was
missed so
we do need to put that back on to the
work plan now whether it has to come
back to a working group or not or
whether we can just continue with it i
need to take advice from you please
yes so and the working group were the
ones that advised last time because they
hadn't heard enough and so my
recommendation would be that we take
that back to the next working group um
for a more thorough review okay thank
you and then i can liaise with
councillor white and be sure that we're
absolutely clear
on uh on that request thank you very
much
members any comments questions
at all
um
thank you jim um no i was um
i'd like to know more about the home
build as well be interested and
quite interesting i didn't even really
know a lot about it so sue council of
white brought it up so
yeah that'd be much appreciated to
find out a bit more about that
definitely and i've been contacted by
resident in birnam in fact who's
interested so yeah that needs to come
back
thank you if there are no um council
messenger i'm sorry thank you madam
chairman and i just was again just to go
on about the enforcement and i do
understand that we were waiting to see
if there was any um
improvement in staffing and enforcement
i just wondered if there has been in
fact
any improvement in staffing with
enforcement
do we know can any of the officers here
tonight help us with that
and i know that there was a resource
agreed but i'm not sure the details on
whether anybody's currently in post or
anything like that i know that um also
officers were due to report back to
committee on this
so i think probably the best thing to do
is if i um get some more details offline
and circulate that to the committee
that's okay that would be great is that
okay that's fine
and perhaps then we could bring that
back on if that's possible yeah
definitely
thank you um so the recommendation is
that we endorse the proposed annual
report for 2122 for submission to the
council can we agree that by sense
yeah agreed agreed super thank you very
much
so that that brings us on to our new
scrutiny item which is item seven
which you'll find on pages 15 to 18
and it's back to you ms hughes if you
would to um present this please
and so this is a report of the working
group who met on the 2nd of march to
review a proposal form that was received
from councillor stamp around the
five-year housing land supply
appendix a page 17-18 of your agenda
pack provides the request details and
preliminary officer review and feedback
on the item
as well as some information that came
out of the discussion at the working
group and their initial consideration
0.4 on page 19 highlights the
suggestions that the working group felt
needed further investigation and the
recommendation is that the committee
approves the working group
recommendation to add this item to the
work plan according to the details set
out in section 3.2 of the covering
report
for officers to then bring a more
detailed report back to the committee
for scrutiny
we invite members to review and feedback
on this report and obviously noting that
the recommendation is to approve the
approach suggested in section 3.2 thank
you thank you very much members any
comments before i go to uh council stamp
no
cancer stamp um i'd like i would really
appreciate your uh
hit your thoughts on the approach and
whether that covers uh what you what you
were hoping for
you can see yeah thank you madam chair
um yes i think it really does need to be
looked in um
and drilled down to the actual detail
um i understand that we're not going to
the reasons and the terms and conditions
of
the terms and reference i'm sorry
chairman
but
we don't really want to find a person at
fault i'm looking more to why it
happened how it happened why policies
weren't in place when the ldp was
approved if there's an actual issue with
the inspector when it was approved
the inconsistency which i
think is actually happening when we're
working out the five-year land supply
why it was only done on an annual basis
and and when officers realized it was
becoming critical
to me it's the the horse has already
bolted from the stable and we all know
the difficult situation that we're
actually in at the moment and i actually
feel it's unacceptable
i think as a council
as i just said robust policies and
monitoring
should have taken place throughout the
plan
not that just kicked in after five years
which is the legal requirement
the five-year land supply
is totally different to the delivery
plan of the houses because we also we
know that we've actually over delivered
um and and i think you may agree with me
madam chair and other members if if they
remember me saying and trying to get
this council to actually write to the
secretary of state on more than one
occasion
especially when kovid
struck and because we knew there would
be a lack of
sights coming forward because of the the
nature of covid the pandemic madam chair
um i don't believe and i i will
apologize if this council has written to
this secretary of state but i don't
believe i've seen a letter but i just
would like to actually bring your
attention to braintree district council
did write to the secretary of state
and if you just allow me to to read a
small part out this actually was written
i think in december last year 2021 so
it's fairly recent but they actually
understood
the issues that was put in their
five-year land supply at risk or the
developers were because obviously they
were citing it um at the time so i won't
read it all but it says it is incredibly
frustrating that we find ourselves being
continually challenged on our housing
supply or the inspectors to make
comments on housing supply in cases
where it has little relevance to that
decision even though we can demonstrate
the five-year hands-online supply using
the government's own method now i know
the officers will come back to me and
say well we can't demonstrate it but i
think like i've said there's been
inconsistencies
with actually working it out
and it says allowing unplanned
development to meet what we believe is
an inflated five-year land supply
calculation destroys public confidence
in the planning system rides roughshod
over strategic plans for infrastructure
and undermines local councillors who've
made incredibly difficult decisions to
approve large levels of growth and have
worked hard to achieve an up-to-date
local plan
we want to assure we want to ensure that
a new high-quality housing is developed
in sustainable locations across the
district and we fully support the
government's objectives to boost housing
supply however they need to access
swiftly and decisively to sort to
resolve the matter now and provide the
necessary level of certainty to
authorities
that are fulfilling the government
policies now i know that they're going
to say well we can't but ma i think that
needs to be taken into consideration you
know that we should have acted sooner uh
and and um i i don't think it's actually
good for um residents and for this
council that i think many of our
residents has lost faith um
our ldp i know it's been it's under
review but like i've said i think that
is because it's it's come because it's
been forced um and i'm just really i'd
like it investigated properly madam
chair i don't know if anybody else wants
to come in and i'll just regroup because
i've got some other notes oh one more um
do do we know when and if our five year
land supply may come back in
as in
is in because you know don't forget the
strategic sites were supposed to meet
the needs yes of the housing and the ldp
so just because all the sites haven't
come forward and we know there's issues
and i actually am going to say and i'm
sure that some developer will write in
and complain about me i think because we
cannot control what speed the developers
are bringing sites forward it is
actually
they are playing playing with a slightly
madam chair
these sites have been agreed and they
could come forward and i think because
we are in a vulnerable position
i don't feel that some some developers
are actually supporting us this
application should have come forward by
now it was in the housing trajectory uh
and yeah okay that was over egged um but
i'm i'm really just not convinced about
what's going on with this ldp and i
think many my post bag is quite full yes
with residents who are very unhappy with
the council so thank you madam chair
thank you likewise as as as you know so
is mine you know it's the biggest issue
planning is is the biggest um
issue that works people so i
wholeheartedly second everything you
you've said cancer stamp and that's
that's
where we need to go and what we need to
know
councilman you look like you want to
comment um no i was just reiterating
what uh
council staff was saying i'd like to
know when we are
or the predicted time of reaching our
housing plan
yeah nice yeah
great thank you anything to add to
council messenger thank you and yeah i'd
like to concur with everything that
councillor stamp has said as well and
i'd also like to drill down and find out
exactly
how this situation has arisen being as
we were supposed to be monitoring this
and to be told consistently that this is
something that we've inherited is not
good enough
so we need to know what's gone on what
the process has been and what it was
supposed to have been and how we've been
left in this dreadful state because
people have lost confidence absolutely
they've lost confidence and i do believe
and they can write in as much as they
like developers are having a real
giraffe at our expense so this needs to
be drilled down and we need to
investigate this and actually i would
like to know who is responsible to be
honest
thank you
well i think members we and officers
were absolutely clear there about uh
about what we're we're looking for here
so um
i am proposing that this item is uh
yeah is approved as a scrutiny item um
as we have just discussed do i have a
second ur can we agree that once then
fabulous
so that is agreed is that some clear
misuse what we were expecting there
yeah yep so it's um everything that was
in the report
just to be clear um
uh i'm not sure we had anything in the
report about applications coming
forwards so i'm not sure if that's an
amendment that you're suggesting to
section 3.2 i am suggesting that as an
amendment please if we could
i just think we need to maximize this we
need we do we need to leave no stone
unturned so i'll second that i mean yes
council messenger second that amendment
we agreed castle
yeah we're agreed on that
super thank you very much
yes
um um thank you madam chair yes so maybe
there's a couple of things that have
have been missed or they they just came
up just now really but uh it's looking
at the the whole issue that is exposed
uh this is what i want to make clear
that has exposed the council to the
position that we're in and why it hasn't
been picked up sooner what why we
haven't had the robust um
um what's the word information or
monitoring or whatever
yeah i really think it is and because
um as what the members have said and
other members have actually voiced
concerns madam chair it's just that i've
raised it
but everybody is very very unhappy that
we have got to got to this stage so
anything that is relevant and i'd like a
full explanation not a narrow
explanation as in sometimes which we
could get so if it could be fully looked
at and not narrowly i think is the best
way to say it you know we we can always
if we don't
get the information we want we will
bring it back
thank you
super councilman madam chair can we also
ask that all the land that has been
brought forward although if accepted or
not accepted is actually made known to
us so we can see
all of the sites that have been brought
forward
yes
so whether can we do that as part of
this or is that too departing from the
item misuse
or can we have that anyway we should
have that we should i mean it's i don't
know why this information is restricted
or it isn't there for us to see can you
help does it feel like a separate
suggestion i would say the best method
for that is maybe to issue a
form so that we can look into that more
thoroughly um because that does feel
separate to the
five-year housing land supply thank you
do about braces do an rns form and a
fresh service and see which comes up
first
thank you very much
thank you
okay so any other items of business that
the chairman of the committee decides
that urgent i have none
so
that means that uh
i now draw the meeting to a close
members thank you thank you very much
for turning out i really appreciate it
and i do fully understand that several
members had genuine commitments or
illnesses tonight but
yet again i want to say my
disappointment with the
lack of seriousness shall we say with
which some members take these meetings
so um yeah very disappointed
thank you again those of you who turned
up and i now close this meeting at
1950.
you